for decades America was run by an
establishment ideology back in
globalization automation centralization
and uncontrolled immigration Republicans
and Democrats alike pushed policies that
favored global business disruptive
technology centralization of power in
the hands of the technocratic
administrative state and a ready supply
of cheap imported labor this ideology
brought huge benefits to the elite
themselves but to the 80% or so of
america's americans outside the booming
centers of the knowledge economy incomes
went down jobs went away and the social
fabric was torn by family breakdown and
community disintegration donald trump
was elected to overturn this elitist
ideology but this week it became clear
that the elite has a new ideology and
this time it's got nothing to do with
policy it's much simpler and less
rational the new elitist ideology is
hatred of Donald Trump and his
supporters the elitists say they're
against populist bigotry and xenophobia
xenophobia means fear and hatred of
strangers is there any better
description of how senior FBI officers
thought of Trump supporters lazy
uneducated POS pieces of sh I T to be
polite as revealed in this week's IG
report the elitists say Donald Trump is
undermining the rule of law but they
born over James Comey who as was also
revealed this week went rogue at the FBI
and put himself above the law the elites
don't care about the rule of law they
just hate Trump they say Donald Trump is
undermining democratic norms but they
continue to try and deal agita Mize a
president who was duly elected according
to the Constitution they don't care
about democratic norms they just hate
Trump this week they condemned the
president for being nice to dictator Kim
jong-un but there's much more cruelty in
human rights abuse in China and the
elite have been sucking up to them for
decades at least with President Trump
the motive was avoiding nuclear war the
elites China suck up was just about
greed look at Bill Maher saying
loud what every Democrat never Trump
Republican things hoping for a recession
so Donald Trump won't get credit for
helping working Americans look at Nancy
Pelosi tried to turn anything positive
into a negative there is nothing not
more jobs not higher incomes not even
less risk of nuclear war that matters
more to these elitist than their
unhinged hatred of Donald Trump and
everything everyone he stands for that
is the new elitist ideology their brand
is hate